so he's someone that's really worked
with me to help
bring me back and be connected here
where my physical body feels like a safe
space
you know we've done a lot of like
healing and releasing of
the things that have happened to the
physical the physical vessel
um so yeah but that's what he does you
know he's it's somatic healing and
he works with the different dimensions
and it's almost it's kind of hard to
even explain
no it it i i it is i mean i it's because
some it's sort of like
felt and not it's like hard to put into
words feelings and
sort of stuff in that realm but it leads
me to sort of the other
i mean i do that stuff too i have a body
worker i mean i've cried because i've
like
given like sound to like a spot that
wouldn't go away
and you know having this release so then
there's also those other layers of
existence and
look i know that you're a chef and i
know that you've bridged that with
spirituality but again it's all
connected and it's like
you know so many people look to a diet
they look to a workout they look to
certain things and they're trying to fix
it but
like then you get to these other spaces
of reality
which are like which are which is
cellular memory
ancestral cellular memory and or even
childhood memory that you can't remember
that you can't remember things that
your body blocks out because there was
too much pain or trauma
and so it takes sometimes these healers
because we
we try everything that seems easy it's
like a baby right we
you know babies crying so it's like um
feed it and then
maybe change its diaper and then um
maybe it needs sleep
and then maybe it's teething and like
there's all kinds of you kind of go
through a checklist
um so it's not always just obvious what
it is but sometimes there's other things
going on that are just
you so you go through your normal
checklist you're like i'm eating right
i'm working out i'm feeling pretty
relaxed i
feel like you've got all these
checklists going on in your life but
it's not
solving what i'm it's i'm not
getting the solution i'm looking for and
so then you get into stuff like with
john
working with the body and even reiki
have you had
stuff uncovered emotionally in your
emotional body
oh absolutely and i've actually worked
with clients
to do that as well i mean that was
something that i
learned because we have such an
emotional connection with food someone's
habits you know or um like things that
they can't seem to really kick
right really comes from an emotional
connection
it can and and i'm so happy we're in
this like space where i can speak so
freely
about my belief system but like
sometimes it's as you said it can be
like from your ancestral lineage you
know it could be something that had
happened in your soul's journey
from maybe even another a past life
and so i've worked with clyde and that's
why like with what i do
in my in culinary alchemy like my
practice which i did on myself
it's just you know i'm looking at your
physical body we go through all your
labs and
everything but then i'm doing the
healing work to connect because
that sugar craving that you may have has
nothing to do with your physical body
has
absolutely something that happened when
you were like five or six or seven
that may be carried on from like what
happened with your mom and once we
figure that out then it's no longer
an issue you have done that many times
and so for myself working with someone
like
john or other healers to release
you know they're definitely traumas
there that i i wasn't even
because you think you're over something
when let's say
you don't cry about it anymore or like
enough
time has passed you can talk about it
without getting emotional
right you think you're you think you're
over it or you think you
i shouldn't say over you think you've
healed from it and
what i learned in this process of
working with
different healers was that there were
there were circumstances there were
situations that had happened in my life
where i thought i had healed from it
because i kind of just like pushed
pushed past sure
i'm not gonna let this take me down you
know
and and really i had just layered on
skin above it you know and so i've
worked with healers and
we've uncovered that and it completely
came out of nowhere where i didn't
even i wasn't expecting that that was
something that was going to come out
um and so that's definitely happened on
on several occasions um with traumas
that have happened
in and there's no other word for it you
know traumas that have happened as
in in my journey